president Trump is blaming Democrats for
the failure so far of efforts to come up
with immigration legislation that
addresses the fate of the so-called
dreamers correspondent Peter Doocy tells
us where things stand right now hello
Peter hi Mike now it is the houses turn
to tackle immigration and the most buzz
is linked to a package authored by
Republican congressman Bob Goodlatte
which addresses border security chain
migration and the Visa Lottery but it
does not include a pathway to
citizenship for dreamers we took a whip
check the whip check was positive and
we're now working on the people who went
back that they were undecided to make
sure that we have the necessary support
and we're prepared to make some more
tweaks to the bill if necessary now that
senators have returned home for recess
without a daca fix president Trump has
tweeted this quote cannot believe how
badly daca recipients have been treated
by the Democrats totally abandoned
Republicans are still working hard that
tweet got a response from the Democratic
whip senator dick durbin who says this
in part quote give me a break you killed
daca and a now rejected six bipartisan
deals to protect dreamers I've been
fighting for dreamers for 17 years and
will never abandon them and across the
capital in the house democratic
congresswoman Michelle Lujan Grisham is
now warning quote now because Trump
sabotage the process of the bipartisan
legislation will continue to see this
crisis worsen as dreamers continue to
lose their jobs and others are detained
and deported it does appear the March
5th deadline president Trump gave
Congress to fix daca maybe moving back
while the administration fights with
federal judges who say the president
can't cancel the program and some
lawmakers think their colleagues
welcome to delay the bottom line is this
also tells me that maybe what's going on
here behind the scenes they don't want
to solve it Democrats Republicans they
want to keep it alive as a campaign
issue a so-called sweet spot on
immigration according to Republican
Senator John Thune could be a stripped
down deal that just addresses the two
big ticket items Dhaka and border
security but there is no deal like that
yet like our Peter Doocy after
immigration week in the United States
Senate Peter many thanks